[Musique]
la chasse à l'homme est ouverte toute
l'année et la france et giboyeuse c'est
ce qu'écrivent deux femmes marianne
antoine et florence remy dans un guide
de la chasse à l'homme qui viennent
paraître elle vise aussi la femme a un
sens inné de la chasse alors pourquoi un
guide
parce que ce qui est important ce n'est
pas de chasser n'importe comment c'est
de chasser pour le plaisir de la
chasseresse également pour le plaisir du
gibier un gibier mal chasser c'est à
gibier souvent perdus pour tout le monde
et pour les autres soit sereine
vous êtes préféré à l'air aux espèces
animales pour classer votre gibier oui
c'était pour résister pour la commodité
et puis enfin parce qu'on l'ait on les
voit mieux ça parle on imagine très
facilement à monsieur qui correspond à
cette description
la chasse bien sûr et tout terrain la
plus courante la chasse en race ville à
découvert est beaucoup moins décevante
que les blasés ne veulent bien le dit
oui parce que la plupart des filles se
promène dans les rues uniquement pour
faire pour faire du shopping vous pour
marcher faire un peu d'exercice est très
souvent elles se plaignent de ne
rencontrer que qu'un gibier extrêmement
médiocre elles se plaignent de ne voir
rien qui vaille la peine c'est parce
qu'elles ne savent pas regarder c'est
parce que non pas l'oeil ouvert
l'achat serait de la chasse est une
attitude c'était une ouverture d'esprit
c'est savoir regarder autour de soi et
on voit de très jolies choses est-ce que
la chasse à l'homme se pratique à mains
nues non non à mains nues c'est vraiment
trop dangereux on est un peu trop
démunis mais il existe des armes
nombreuses et nous pourrions dire aux
femmes pour les encourager avant toute
chose que il est une arme à qui elle
prête absolument toutes les forces et
qui n'existe pas c'était une arme
mythique c'est la jeunesse la beauté et
voire même la richesse on peut leur dire
une chose c'est vraiment ça c'est une
chose qui n'est pas forcément nécessaire
il y serait évidemment exagéré de dire
que quand on est laide bête est pauvre
on va réussir plus vite que les autres
mais ça n'est pas nécessaire
ces armes sont nombreuses et les porte
en elle il faut qu elle s'y croit un
petit peu et il faut qu'elle apprenne à
s'en servir
il ya des armes légères que nous
conseillons aux 80 en particulier elles
pourront toujours sentir après mais pour
commencer c'est plus encourageant des
armes lourdes et même d arme à double
tranchant
et alors nous pouvons recommander
puisque nous parlons aux débutantes une
seule arme lourde qui dengue dans le
maniement est extrêmement facile c'est
l'admiration
ça c'est le bazooka on peut faire la
taille la taille des le calibre maximum
ça marche toujours les amateurs
s'il respectait les chasses gardées à
priori oui a priori absolument une
chasse gardée à tout va bien fair play
entre chasseresse ne plaçons pas si vous
voulez sur le plan d'une morale
conventionnelle mais tout de même il ya
simplement en matière de d'élégance si
vous voulez entre les chasseresses des
choses qui se font et des choses qui ne
se font pas
donc a priori il faut respecter les
chasses gardées seulement évidemment il
ya des cas d'espèce parfois est ce pas
la chasse est très très mal gardé la
chasseresse propriétaire est absente où
elle se désintéresse complètement du
gibier sur lequel elle avait
primitivement jeté son dévolu dans ce
cas là on peut dire qu'il peut être
compréhensible excusable de piétiner un
peu de braconner sur sur à sur un
terrain donc garder tôt pour vous le
mariage n'est pas incompatible avec la
chasse non absolument pas et il faut
dire également que chasser n'est pas
nécessairement consommer n'est ce pas
ces îles c'est une erreur absolue
ça arrive souvent que les femmes ce qui
se téléphonent beaucoup annoncent à une
amie ça y'est gérard je laisse haye et
michel est à ma main ça y est christian
est tombé il ne faudrait pas crier
victoire trop tôt d'abord parce que
elles vont se faire une réputation
menteuse et ensuite parce que le le
gibier finira par le savoir et par faire
fuir les petites proies qui se
laisserait volontiers à frapper
autrement depuis l'âge de pierre l'homme
primitif se réserver exclusivement le
privilège de la chasse l'homme civilisé
se sentent ils chasseurs gibier
précis je veux ça enterré chasseurs
voyez normal que les femmes se
transforme en chasserait ce serait ça
serait pas si mal que simple chacun son
groupe
ou chasseurs de gibier d'eau en temps
oui finalement elle arrive assez souvent
à faire ce qu'elles veulent il a décidé
elle-même
où est la venue rencontrer vous adresser
la parole les premières vous et ce n'est
pas mon départ mais quelles raisons
beaucoup dans les utilisent maintenant
les avait toujours eu enfin elles les
utilisent plus librement
parce que vous pensez qu'elle ne les
utilisez pas autrefois n'auraient pas
non et qu'est ce que vous comptez du
braconnage braconnage est encore
attendue encore été dit ou pensé que si
je sentis en quelques années on le
prendra encore d'autres libertés comme
les hommes un belle mais ils en prennent
aussi au oui depuis longtemps oui et
vous conseiller une différence entre les
libertés que les hommes et connaîtra
encore un peu oui quand même
heureusement oui je dois j'aimerais
avoir l'avis d'un canard enchaîné d'un
gibier du pigeon enchaîné mais écoutez
je crois que c'est très agréable pour
monsieur ne se sentirait traqué moi je
ne manque que ça je demande comme
poursuivre comment ben jusque dans mes
derniers retranchements et je suis prêt
à céder si on veut du bien
je me donne volontiers je suis le gibier
le plus facile à piège parce
qu'effectivement maxi méridionale
c'était un peu fatigant de courir après
des dames mais si les dames se met à
courir après vous c'est pas moi qui
fuiraient je défendrai toujours présent
[Musique]